woods est née au nigeria et pas par
exemple au sénégal au mali
tout le monde est un homme d'affaires
ont déjà conduit un homme comme femme
tout le monde et businessman mais c'est
assez impressionnant donc nollywood est
clairement le vent en poupe et les
budgets ce qui est gros budgets des
films à gros budget comme aux états unis
ou même en france qu'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le record de budget aux
nigériens ses 9 millions de dollars et
monter en gamme
d'un point de vue technique
niveau des histoires racontées et s'est
du coup ça implique effectivement des
budgets beaucoup plus important donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent et
beaucoup de pays en afrique francophone
notamment qui regarde puisque au nigeria
et qui apprennent et qui essaye de faire
pareil c'est quoi cette merde
depuis l'année dernière la quantité de
drogue saisie a augmenté d'environ 4
180%
on m'a arrêté en pensant que j'étais
membre d'un gang un poc
après j'étais suspecté de 10
[Applaudissements]
ici la plupart des femmes courageux sera
longue peine de prison différente un
milieu nous avons inventé ce concours
pour le remonter un peu le moral je veux
sortir
je suis déterminé à remporter le titre
miss talavera bruit
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi à l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et avec nos repères faire voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 13
juillet 2020 le premier ministre jean
castex parle d'un moment historique les
accords trouvés lors du ségur de la
santé ont été officiellement signé cet
après midi parmi les cinq syndicats de
praticiens hospitaliers deux n'ont pas
accepté de signer l'accord salarial
proposé par le gouvernement
elle certains appellent même à une
journée d'action nationale le 14 juillet
à la crainte d'une deuxième vague en
france plus de 300 foyers de
contamination ont été identifiés sur le
territoire à des médecins appellent au
port du masque obligatoire dans les
espaces publics clos assez dans ce
contexte qu olivier vers en organisant
ce moment une soirée de remerciements
pour les soignants impliqué depuis des
mois dans la lutte contre le colis de 19
demain à les armées seront céder la
première place aux soignants emmanuel
macron s'est adressé tout à l'heure aux
armes et à la veille du 14 juillet le
traditionnel défilé militaire se
déroulera cette année son public et sera
remplacé par une cérémonie je cite
symbole de résilience
une journée dédiée aux personnes civiles
et militaires engagés dans la lutte
contre le coc vite 19
avec le break site en vue le royaume uni
va consacrer 768 millions d'euros pour
renforcer ses frontières une somme pour
être prêt dès la fin de la période de
transition instaurée pour permettre aux
deux anciens partenaires de négocier
leur relation concernant les
négociations une nouvelle session doit
se tenir la semaine du 20 juillet à
londres avec l'union européenne
[Musique]
après six semaines de négociations pour
refonder l'hôpital français les accords
salariaux ont été signés il ya quelques
heures entre le gouvernement et des
syndicats
le ségur de la santé avait été proposé
par emmanuel macron un moment historique
selon le premier ministre
autre son de cloche du côté de certains
syndicats écoutez les précisions de
notre journaliste katia technique après
sept semaines de négociations les
accords du ségur portant sur les
revalorisations des personnels
hospitaliers se des ehpad ont été signés
il porte sur une enveloppe de 8,1
milliards d'euros
alors jean castex le nouveau premier
ministre a estimé qu'il témoignait de la
reconnaissance à l'égard de celles et
ceux qui étaient en première ligne
quant au ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand il a salué un accord historique
de par son ampleur en effet il va
permettre de procéder à des
augmentations socle pour tous les
personnels hospitaliers non médicaux qui
peuvent être des brancardiers
infirmières des aides soignantes des
revendications qu'ils portaient tout de
même depuis plus d'un an dans la rue en
tout cas ces négociations ont permis de
les satisfaire sur ce point je vous
propose d'écouter le ministre
je sais la force de l'engagement pour
ces professionnels du quotidien et donc
être capable aujourd'hui d'être le
ministre qui permet à ce million et demi
de salariés d'avoir une augmentation ce
qu'il faut rentrer dans les chiffres de
183 euros nets mensuels pour toute
personne qui travaille à l'hôpital
auquel s'ajoute un deuxième volet via un
travail sur les grilles indiciaires pour
que les métiers qui sont les plus en
tension notamment les infirmiers aides
soignants mais pas que puisse avoir
encore un gain équivalent 35 euros net
par mois
tout cela ce ne sont pas des primes tout
cela monsieur le premier ministre c'est
en bas à droite de la feuille de paye ça
compte dans la vie professionnelle ça
compte au moment de la retraite et puis
le troisième volet de la fusée de cette
revalorisation
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'engagement
collectif
l'engagement collectif c'est la capacité
qu'auront demain les équipes de
s'organiser au sein des hôpitaux pour
être capable de porter des projets
améliorant la qualité des soins pour les
malades et pourquoi 10h que toutes les
revendications n'ont pas été satisfaites
et bien parce que tous les syndicats
n'ont pas signé à l'heure concernant
l'accord du ségur portant sur la
revalorisation des salaires des
personnels hospitaliers non médecin la
cfdt est fort et unsa ont signé mais pas
la cgt par exemple les autres syndicats
estiment
cet accord n'est par exemple qu'une
imposture une grande déception
concernant l'accord sur les médecins les
médecins hospitaliers et bien là encore
du grand mécontentement chez les
syndicats que nous avons pu suivre ce
matin en effet il estime que l'
enveloppe de 450 millions d'euros n'est
pas à la hauteur il attendait au moins
un milliard voire plus
alors pourquoi sont-ils insatisfaits
bien parce que les augmentations de
salaires promises ne concerne que la fin
de carrière il n'y a rien sur les gardes
par exemple ou les heures
supplémentaires
et quant aux salaires d'embauché des
jeunes médecins il est jugé insuffisant
c'est pourquoi certains syndicats vont
se réunira dès demain il ya là la cgt
sud santé les amuse les urgentistes snpl
le syndicat infirmier
ils vont se rassembler au cours d'une
marche demain keira de république à
bastille et d'autres races en pleine
pleut mans sont prévues sur tout le
territoire français
alors si l'accord sur la rémunération
des médecins hospitaliers conclu dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé est à marquer
d'une pierre blanche est ce pour autant
une véritable avancée pour le secteur
hospitalier la crise sanitaire inédite
va-t-elle permettre de faire évoluer le
statut des personnels en première ligne
on en parle tout de suite avec florence
bouscat vice-présidente du collectif
inter bloc et avec thierry amouroux rue
porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers fluence
bousquet thiery amoureux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
parmi les principales mesures
une rouge 283 euros nets pour les
personnels soignants 450 millions pour
les médecins hospitaliers
une enveloppe de 55 millions pour les
internes des hausses de salaires pour
les personnels paramédicaux ou encore
des embauches c'est historique selon les
mots du premier ministre est ce que vous
rejoignez son enthousiasme florence
bousquet en fait c'est très mitigé 1
j'ai un peu l'impression d'être
insidieusement projeté dans la peau du
docteur faust et avec l'alléchant a pas
de 180 euros qu'on nous conte nommer un
petit peu à toutes les sauces mais ce
que je lis surtout sur les sur les
accords s'apparente plutôt à un pacte un
peu démoniaque parce que
ya beaucoup de petites à l'ena ou en
fait savoir en condition oui un pacte
démoniaque pourquoi précisément par
exemple le temps de repos entre deux
prises de postes qui étaient avant de
12h à pass à 11 heures le temps de
travail qui étaient 35 heures va être
augmenté à 40 heures il ya beaucoup de
choses en fait qu'ils sont pas annoncés
mais qui sont mis en tout petit comme
dans les assurances vous savez les
petits alinéa quand on lit pas en fin de
contrat ça fait la même chose en fait
thiery hameau c'est petit alinéa en fin
de contrat comme vient de le souligner
florence bousquet vous aussi vous font
peur oui puis surtout on nous avions
trois revendications ouvrir des lits
créer des postes et revaloriser les
salaires sur la réouverture de lignes à
rien ils ont même refusé d un moratoire
alors que ce qui se passe sur le terrain
c'est qu'ils continuent à fermer des
lignes au mois de juillet nous avons
moins d'hélico mois de janvier ils n'ont
pas du tout tenu compte de l'expérience
du duc au vide
même en alsace ils ont fermé 14 lits de
réanimation à strasbourg ils ont fermé
la réanimation de sélestat enfin bon au
niveau des postes
j'espère on crée 7500 sachant qu'il ya
déjà des milliers de postes non pourvus
parce que vous comprenez bien que
travailler sous payés on sous-effectif
dont des conditions travaillent parfois
lamentable il ya un des milliers de
postes qui restent vacants à l'hôpital
mais juste payant frein sur les salaires
alors là il faut bien comprendre que
cette année il n'y a pas un centime pour
les luttes pour les professionnels de
l'hôpital va y avoir une loi qui sera
votée en décembre
et puis ensuite des décrets d arrêter et
cetera qui fait que sur la paille de fin
février les personnes en fin
une hausse de 90 euros rétroactive de
quelques mois mais enfin c'est pas grand
chose
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui s'il ya eu
un mouvement si fort des personnels
infirmiers c'est parce que nous sommes
sous payé 21 pour cent de moins que le
restant de des infirmiers et européens
et finalement est ce que est ce que ces
hausses de salaires finalement est ce
que justement elle se réajuste par
rapport au reste des infirmiers européen
pas du tout là où on était à -1 21% l'an
prochain avec ses 183 euros nous serons
à -10%
donc on sera un peu moins sous payés non
sera quand même largement sous payés
donc ce n'est pas possible
alors ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que du coup les gens ils votent
avec leurs pieds 1
c'est à dire que il démissionne de
l'hôpital les plus jeunes par travailler
à l'étranger dans les pays frontaliers
pour ceux qui parlent l'anglais dans les
pays anglo-saxons et puis ben voilà il
ya vous avez des milliers de postes
aujourd'hui qui sont non pourvus à
l'hôpital florence k -o
inon fluence bousquet ces hausses de
salaires qui ont été signés cet après
midi finalement est-ce que ça va
permettre un petit peu plus
d'attractivité dans le secteur
hospitalier selon mais pas du tout pas
du tout parce qu'en fait c'est de la
poudre de perlimpinpin qu'on nous jette
à la figure déjà au niveau des postes il
faut savoir qu'ils nous proposent à peu
près quinze mille postes
sachant que ça fait à peu près dix
postes par établissement parce qu'il ya
mille trois cent soixante établissements
en france alors qu'il faudrait pour les
ehpad trois cent mille postes en plus
100 milles pour les hôpitaux de gagner
on est loin du compte donc travailler
dans des conditions où le personnel sera
mis à rude épreuve
parce qu'en fait il ya très peu de
personnel ça c'est pas possible les gens
vont pas il n'y a pas d'acte réactivité
possible la qualité de vie au travail
c'est tout simplement on reconnaît pas
la pénibilité de notre profession donc
il est évident que il y aura pas plus de
l'infirmier qui vont travailler à
l'hôpital
en tout cas
désaccord finalement autour des hausses
des salaires non moi on a moins parlé de
restructuration de l'hôpital qui était
aussi montré du doigt thierry amouroux
effectivement c'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui selon vous oui puis il faut
bien comprendre qu'il ya trop
d'administratifs il ya toute la
technostructure des ars quelque chose à
supprimer parce que ça fait beaucoup
d'emplois et micky et coûte très cher
vous avez 11 mille agents ministère de
la santé dans une ère s prenons par
exemple la grèce ile de france vous avez
1200 agents et bien si on supprime et là
il reste pour confier les missions au
conseil régional avec eux sur l'exemple
des länder allemands un ministre de la
santé régional eh bien on voit que les
gens seraient proches du terrain est
capable de mieux connaître le territoire
de mieux réagir alors que les ars ont
été en dessous de tout pendant la femme
que vides et 1200 places d'arrêt
supprimer ça permet créé 3600 postes
d'infirmières et les soignantes à
l'hôpital donc c'est vite vous savez
quand on compare l'allemagne et la
france nous avons en france 30%
d'infirmières en moins et 35% des
ministres actifs en plus donc si on veut
faire des économies on peut en faire
quoi
les derniers statistiques de l'insee
vous avez plus de 102 mille agents
administratifs à l'hôpital alors que
vous avez que 71 1000 médecins et 30000
interne plus d'administratif que deux
médecins
il ya quand même un souci fluence
bousquet à quel type de restructuration
vous vous attendez finalement en fait on
est un peu déçu ça a été menée de façon
frénétique depuis sept semaines et on
n'a pas du tout consultez les les
professionnels de terrain puisque les
infirmiers qui représente quand même
sept cent mille en france ont été
complètement évincé
donc tout le reste ça va tout le reste
va en fait suivre c'est à dire que ce
qui concerne la formation
ça fait déjà depuis 2008 personnellement
qu'aux blocs opératoires les ibode
demande la réingénierie de leur diplôme
on leur accorde pas par contre bon je me
félicite quand même pour
pour nos collaborateurs qui sont
diététiciens préparateur en pharmacie
élaborons un lieu où on va avoir la
réingénierie de leur diplôme mais voilà
nous on est toujours dans la tente
depuis 2008
et c'est une spécialisation quand même
qui a besoin de progresser on en demande
de plus en plus de technicité de
qualification de compétences et voilà
donc les postes qui vont suivre les
futurs piliers sur la formation seront
menées de la même façon qu'on était
menés les rémunérations c'est à dire on
craint le pire à l'orf lance bousquet
thierry amouroux vous restez avec nous
parce qu'en ce moment même une grande
fête pour les soignants a lieu au grand
palais c'est à paris 800 personnels
hospitaliers ont été conviés par le
ministère de la santé
une soirée de remerciement est dommage
l'umq à laquelle participent olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé
pour plus de précisions on va tout de
suite retrouvé devant le grand palais
notre reporter thomas bonnin à thomas
bon soir alors qu'elle est dans quelle
atmosphère se déroule cette soirée
mais écoutez les invités continuent à
arriver ici au grand palais les
retardataires puisque la soirée démarre
officiellement à 20 heures soirée vous
l'avait dit pour remercier le personnel
soignant le personnel soignant qui
étaient en première ligne pendant la
crise du coville 19 qu'ils sont 800
soignants avoir été conviés pour cette
soirée il vous propose d'écouter l'un
d'entre eux s'appelle jean baptiste il
est originaire de la région nouvelle
aquitaine et les venues prêter main
forte aux hôpitaux en région parisienne
il nous explique dans quel état d'esprit
ils abordent cette soirée donc en
compagnie du ministre des solidarités de
la santé je proposais les côtés je pense
que c'est l'heure du symbolique
aujourd'hui c'est la symbolique après
effectivement il ya eu aujourd'hui des
avancées au niveau des studios la santé
après je pense que l'image du grand
poète de me recevoir aujourd'hui c'est
plus un symbolique pour le gouvernement
aujourd'hui effectivement qu'on m'a
appelé il ya un mois je me questionnais
sur l'intérêt de venir ou pas voilà je
suis pas personnellement moi je ne fais
pas plus plusieurs courses après je suis
je suis content surtout de représenter
les gens à qui j'ai travaillé en
banlieue parisienne qui sont des gens
avec professionnalisme et qui qui était
qui s'est dévoué vraiment pour la
passion et je suis content avec l'apport
kyoto vous l'avez entendu cette soirée
intervient dans un contexte particulier
puisque aujourd'hui les accords du ségur
de la santé ont été signés et le
personnel soignant sera également de la
partie demain pour la cérémonie du 14
juillet dans la capitale mais dans cette
soirée il n'y a pas que des soignants il
ya aussi des personnes issues de la
société civile ou encore des membres de
la cellule de crise du ministère mais
aussi des proches de soignants qui ont
perdu la vie pendant cette pandémie de
covile 19 là encore je propose d'écouter
d'autres témoignages
une famille qui a perdu à un proche
pendant cette crise donc c'est au micro
de sindia l'auberge
c'est un bel événement après j'aurais
aimé pouvoir vivre ça mais
dans d'autres conditions ce que c'est
suite quand même un événement tragique
donc c'est un peu particulier
on a été invité par la rs étant donné
que c'était on va travailler à l'hôpital
en tant que personnel soignant on a été
un conviés par la rs c'est quelque chose
de bien après ça n'efface pas ce qui
s'est passé le nombre de moyens qui a pu
y avoir en tout cas dans les hôpitaux
voilà donc pour cette soirée qui se
déroule au grand palais le grand palais
qui accueille gracieusement cette soirée
dans une forme de mécénat avec le
gouvernement puis à noter que évidemment
malgré les tenues de soirée les
participants sont amenés à porter un
masque puisque selon le ministre de la
santé les gestes barrières devant
impérativement être respectée ce soir
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnin en direct
devant le grand palais à paris et ont
continué de parler de ces accords du
ségur de la santé avec vous florence
bousquet vice présidente du collectif
inter bloc et avec vous tirez amoureux
porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers peut-être un
mot sur cette soirée ce soir
tout d'abord est ce que vous avez été
invité et qu'elle elle regarde ont porté
sur cette initiative du ministère de la
santé
alors personnellement nous n'avons pas
été invité en tant que collectif interne
bloc et le regard que j'ai de cette
soirée c'est encore mitigé parce que
normalement le coville devait être
reconnu comme maladie professionnelle
pour tous les soignants et petit à petit
on apprend qu en fait seuls les
soignants qui ont été gravement touchés
et qu'ils auront de graves séquelles par
la suite seront reconnues comme maladies
professionnelles donc c'est toujours des
annonces et derrière ils se cachent des
choses qui sont faites dramatique pour
les soignants c'est comme pour les prime
de 1500 euros qui auront finalement été
donné avec parcimonie voir que 2 500
euros à certains n'y a pas d'autre et
c'est toujours des effets de style qui
sont dramatiques pour les soignants qui
ont été et qui ont répondu vraiment
présent chaque fois qu'ils ont été
sollicités et autour de moi j'entends
j'entends des soignants qui disent la
prochaine vague ça sera sans moi et je
pense que le gouvernement doit entendre
aussi ce
cet appel parce que je suis pas certaine
que tout le monde répondra présent votre
avis sur sur cette soirée ce soir au
grand palais c'est une action de
communication qui cache l'élément qui
aujourd'hui parce que moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que au bout de deux
mois de déconfinement on est toujours en
manque de moyens à l'hôpital c'est à
dire que on est en tension sur les gants
sur les / blues / les médicaments
d'anesthésié et donc demain si on est
confronté à une deuxième vague mais
comment va-t-on faire
on a l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas
encore tiré les leçons des manque cruel
de la première vague qui ont abouti à
des morts qui auraient pu être évitable
si on avait eu le matériel nécessaire et
on se retrouve confronté à la même
situation nous mêmes en tant que
soignant on n'a toujours pas de masques
ffp2 en quantité suffisante
donc voilà on est quand même très
inquiet le fait qu'ils continuent à
fermer des lits ça veut dire que on aura
encore moins 10 pour répondre aux
besoins en cas de cette deuxième vague
et puis surtout on voit bien que du coup
on n'a pas les capacités pour prendre en
soins
tous les patients non qu'ovide qui ont
été déprogrammés en mars avril mai et
par contre donc des patients qui ont des
pathologies chroniques des interventions
chirurgicales programmées et non
urgentes qui ont été repoussés mais qui
vont être voir repoussé de nombreux mois
parce que alors que l'on devrait prendre
plus de monde en fait ils réduisent les
moyens donc on n'arrive pas à absorber
le retard sur le planning des mois
qu'ovide flanc soutien
c'est inquiétant florence bousquet est
ce que vous confirmez ce que vous venez
d'entendre ce que vient de nous dire
thierry amouroux à savoir eh bien il ya
encore une pénurie de matériel
aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux alors tout
à fait et pas seulement dans les
hôpitaux puisque c'est aussi valable
pour les crimes les cliniques privées
puisque moi je fais partie des du privé
où on manque effectivement de masse de
callot de blues stérilisables c'est à
dire que pour travailler au bloc
opératoire il nous faut des détenus
stérile et on manque au monde déjà avant
même qu'ils aient la vague qui va
arriver au manque de matériels donc
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique ça
c'est quelque chose que vous remontez
aux autorités régulièrement
bien sûr les ars sont tout à fait au
courant puisqu'il délivre au compte
gouttes les curares et les les
hypnotiques donc même pour les
interventions on est obligé de jongler
en disant qu'on va être tel patient
celui-là on va lui faire juste une loco
régionale
il aura pas d'âge et on est obligé voilà
deux de fer avec le matériel et c'est
c'est une fois plus dramatique thiam on
est quand même la sixième puissance
mondiale et on se dit comment est ce
possible
thierry amouroux vous confirmer que s'il
ya une deuxième vague ça sera encore la
catastrophe c'est ce que vous nous dites
ce soir on va avoir un nouveau problème
de manque de moyens de protection et
donc du coup ben les personnes
deviennent contaminantes à leur tour et
il y est vous avez entendu la différence
on est obligé de baisser les doses ou de
trouver des substituts pas pour les
produits d'un et saisit donc on était
déjà confronté à ça pendant la première
vague
c'est un vrai souci de santé publique et
les moyens ne sont pas ni suffisamment
sûre sur l'hôpital il faut absolument
qu'on réorganise sa queue on produise
les médicaments en france qu'on produise
le matériel en france de façon à être
indépendant parce que là on est
complètement dépendant du marché mondial
comme tout le monde
voeux du matériel en ce moment il n'y a
pas assez de matières produits et de
matières premières et de produits finis
et c'est un vrai souci
visiblement bas on ne met pas à
l'appareil industriel français en
capacité de répondre aux besoins de
santé de la population au revient dans
la logique faut fabriquer des voitures
pour fabriquer des avions
ben non personne les achète d une
réduction de l'aviation enfin voilà on a
l'impression qu'ils vivent pas dans le
monde réel
en tout cas bon il ya eu cette hausse de
salaire aujourd'hui on en a parlé pour
tous les soignants
demain il ya cet hommage durant le 14
juillet un hommage aux soignants hommage
national
cette soirée ce soir on en a parlé
également au grand palais pour les
soignants
malgré tout cela vous estimez que le
gouvernement ne vous entend pas ne vous
écoute pas d aviation qui nous écoutent
pas il a il a pas du tout entendu nos
revendications donc on ne peut pas
laisser faire des choses comme ça et du
reste de ma il ya un appel national
qu'est lancée par par tous les partout
les mouvements infirmiers pour démontrer
une fois de plus notre mécontentement
justement pour conclure là après l'autre
thiery amoureux vous vous serez demain
dans la rue pour défiler pour le
l'hôpital bien sûr il ya des dizaines de
mouvements dans toute la france et il y
en a un qui part de république à 14h
pour aller à bastille
voilà c'est pour continuer à maintenir
la pression
on demande également à la population de
de saisir les maires qui sont ceux qui
président les l'instance de l'hôpital de
saisir les parlementaires qui vont voter
le budget des hôpitaux
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça il
faut vraiment mettre des moyens sur
l'hôpital parce que derrière il ya des
morts vous comprenez que en france on a
cinq fois moins de lits de réanimation
que l'allemagne et on a eu quatre fois
plus de morts là on n'est pas simplement
des salariés qui dit fonds dont leur
outil de travail
on est des soignants qui alertons sur la
population la population
sur les planches et enfin la population
est en danger parce qu'il n'ya pas assez
moyen on a fermé quantité de lit on a
fermé des petits hôpitaux des petites
maternités des petits services d'urgence
et aujourd'hui la france n'a que 5,9
lits pour 1000 habitants
là où l'allemagne en a huit plants
bousquet en un mot pour conclure moi je
conclurai juste sur l'aspect financier
c'est à dire que l'état fait un peu
marchands de tapis avec nos
rémunérations à payer en deux fois et
seulement une partie de nos pulls ce
qu'on avait demandé mais là ce qui
s'annonçait que financièrement il va
falloir mettre beaucoup plus d'argent
pour acheter tout ce matériel qui
manquent et les prix sont en train de
flamber parce qu'il n'y a pas de matière
première comme disait thierry donc il va
bien falloir qu'ils trouvent de l'argent
et une fois de plus ça ça n'aura pas été
anticipée et voilà c'est donc c'est une
vraie catastrophe
si à tous les deux en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation directe sur air
france lance bousquet je rappelle que
vous êtes vice présidente du collectif
inter-blogues thiery amouroux porte
parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers merci à tous
les deux restez avec nous sur rt france
on poursuit cette édition dans quelques
instants retour sur le discours aux
armes et des manuels macron et puis
focus sur le 14 juillet le traditionnel
défilé militaire sur les champs elysées
est remplacée par une cérémonie sans
public place de la concorde avec un
hommage appuyé aux soignants en première
ligne durant le colis depuis direction
le royaume uni il a consacré 768
millions d'euros au renforcement de ses
frontières en vue du bric site à rester
avec nous sur rtl france
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons quels rapports nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente vers une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
pourquoi une banque disparaîtrait pas
pourquoi pas bien sûr la banque ne gagne
pas d'argent sur son métier traditionnel
mais gagne de l'argent uniquement sur
des opérations marche deux mois de non
consommation mondiale et les plus gros
groupe s'arrête et 10 on n'a pas de
trésorerie
c'est un modèle assez extraordinaire à
la banque c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était privatisation des
gains et mutualisation des pertes donc
en fait c'est fâcheux gagne pile tu
perds ont créé une économie qui l'a zéro
valeur
statistiquement vous aurez une banque en
europe une banque majeur en europe
tissot crapules
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française demain à les armer sort ont
cédé la place aux soignants ce sont les
mots il y a environ une heure des
manuels macron depuis l'hôtel de brienne
le chef de l'état a prononcé son
discours aux armées il a notamment
remercié les militaires qui ont
participé à la lutte contre l'épidémie
de coronavirus nous devons poursuivre
l'effort initie pour moderniser notre
outil de défense at il également assuré
on les écoute nous entourons les
familles endeuillées de ceux qui ont
perdu la vie dans ce combat autour de
vous soldats marins aviateurs autour du
personnel médical autour des forces de
sécurité autour de tous ceux qui ont mis
leurs forces leurs compétences leur
humanité dans cette bataille contre le
virus cette cérémonie sera le symbole de
l'engagement de toute une nation
je veux encore salué les soignants du
service de santé des armées ainsi que
leur directrice et tous ceux qui les ont
appuyés et qui à leur côté on permet de
soulager le secteur hospitalier civile
une vingtaine d'entre eux sont encore
récemment encore précemment parti
renforcer la guyane nos médecins et
infirmiers militaires ont fait et font
une fois de plus honneur
alors glorieux anciens et aux armées
françaises allaient secours du chef de
l'état aux armes et à la veille du 14
juillet emmanuel macron va renouer avec
une tradition présidentielle qu'il avait
supprimé l interview télévisée le jour
de la fête nationale une prise de parole
très attendu à crise sanitaire port du
masque obligatoire sécurité écrit
sociales et économiques les précisions
de walid menadi il y un an emmanuel
macron descendez les champs-elysées tout
sourire à bord d'un véhicule militaire
défilé des troupes hommage aux soldats
une célébration dans la peau d'un
président plutôt détendu
aujourd'hui le contexte est bien
différent crise sanitaire économique
le chef de l'état a choisi cette fois ci
de renouer avec la tradition de
l'interview du 14 juillet pour tenter de
répondre aux nombreuses inquiétudes des
français
il y a quelques jours les grandes lignes
de l'acte 2 du quinquennat ont
d'ailleurs été annoncé sur twitter
ensemble nous traçons les contours de ce
nouveau chemin qui sera centré sur la
reconstruction économique social
environnemental et culturel de notre
pays
avec cette interview emmanuel macron
ravive une vieille tradition
présidentielle initiée par valéry
giscard d'estaing en 1978 lors d'une
garden party à l'elysée
un exercice que l'ancien chef d'état va
répéter durant tout son septennat sans
successeur françois mitterrand va lui
aussi se prêter au jeu des
questions-réponses bicentenaire de la
révolution française lutte contre le
chômage est de développement immigration
autant de sujets abordés par le
socialiste au cours des douze entretiens
accordés entre 1982 et 1993 doit son
côté jacques chirac va s'emparer de ce
rendez-vous avec le sens de la formule
quand je me suis aperçu du chiffre
exorbitant que l'on m'impute est au
titre de ses voyages privés lors de mon
mandat
ce n'est pas que ces sommes se dégonfle
c'est qu'elle fonctionne il n'y a pas de
différend entre le ministre des finances
nicolas sarkozy et moi
pour une raison simple c'est que
notamment s'agissant de la dépense
je décide et il exécute arrivée au
pouvoir en 2007 nicolas sarkozy va
supprimer ce rituel remis plus tard au
goût du jour par françois hollande en
le président socialiste se livrent une
dernière fois à l'exercice et en profite
pour critiquer les ambitions
présidentielles de celui qui était alors
son ministre de l'économie
un certain emmanuel macron il ya des
règles la solidarité l'esprit d'équipé
la nécessité de servir jusqu'au bout
dans un gouvernement il n'y a pas de
démarche personnelle encore moins de
démarche présidentielle
ce jour de fête nationale emmanuel
macron va donc renouer avec cette
entrevue annuel et sera interrogé en
direct par deux journalistes 45 minutes
pour tenter de convaincre les français à
deux ans de la prochaine présidentielle
et pour parler de la cérémonie inédite
du 14 juillet mais aussi revenir sur le
discours d' emmanuel macron aux armes et
nous sommes avec mercedes crespin elle
est présidente de l'association soutien
et protection des troupes mais également
auteur du livre un bon petit soldat aux
éditions flammarion
mercedes crespin merci à d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pour commencer votre réaction
le chef de l'état a prononcé donc son
discours aux armées il est environ une
heure il a dit que les armées seront
cédés à la place aux soignants comment
avez vous reçu et compris cette
déclaration coûte et on la comprend
comment la comprend habituellement nos
soldats on t'a chef des armées et quand
le chef des armées parle bien évidemment
nous sommes dans la pièce ceci dit ce 14
juillet à commun un goût d'amertume
monsieur c'est à dire que cette absence
de défilés militaires c'est cela qui
vous donne ce sentiment d'amertume ce
soir oui absolument
un maire dessus tristesse pour pour la
première fois depuis des années donc ce
rendez vous entre la nation et
r et nous force armée n'aura pas lieu
demain parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
défilé mais d'une cérémonie restreinte
quelques unités seront présentes ou
représentées feront le tour de la place
de la concorde dont le chef des armées
s'est invitée ce n'est pas le défilé ce
n'est pas leur rendez vous entre la
nation et nous forces armées auquel nous
sommes habitués ce rendez-vous qui est
attendu chaque année entre les
françaises et les français et leurs
militaires n'aura pas lieu demain
même si le service d'e santé aux armées
va être largement représenté demain il y
aura un hommage aux six militaires
également même cela ça ça ne suffit pas
selon vous je pense ou vu des réactions
des commentaires je peux avoir sur sur
la page de force et honneur
je comprends bien que il est évident
qu'il faut il faut mettre en lumière le
service de santé des armées et le rôle
essentiel primordial qu'il a joué dans
le dans la crise que nous avons
traversée
le confinement le service de santé a été
là il a marqué sa présence il a répondu
présent
ceci dit ceci dit monsieur le 14 juillet
c'est le défilé nos forces armées sur
les champs elysées menée par le chef des
armées notre président monsieur mâcon et
demain ce sera 20 cas même s'il ya une
reconnaissance que nous devons à notre
service de santé des armées qui entre
parenthèses porte se porte très mal
il n'y a pas si longtemps donc un
rapport sénatorial a souligné que notre
service de santé tellement sollicité
aussi bien dans la crise du colis que au
sahel et et bien se porte très mal à une
il ya un problème de personnel de
personnel et et voilà demain bien
évidemment il ya une reconnaissance à
robert tous et tous ses personnels mais
n'oublions pas qu'il traverse aussi une
crise alors on va on va y revenir à
cette crise vous nous dites que les
militaires traverse aujourd'hui une
crise mais on le sait pendant la crise
du coc vide des militaires étaient
engagés sur le terrain que ce soit sur
le territoire français ou en opérations
extérieures notamment vous en parliez
pendant le engagé sur l'opération barkan
au sahel
est ce que les militaires et leurs
familles que vous rencontrez se sentent
abandonnées aujourd'hui écoutés
l'abandon cécile ça serait ça serait un
petit peu lourd en termes il y as
certainement demain sentiment de 2 me
sur le côté abandon j'irai pas jusque là
je dirais simplement que demain je le
répète pour la première fois depuis la
libération il n'y aura pas de défilé sur
les champs-elysées il n'y aura pas ce
lien entre la nation et nos soldats
cette reconnaissance cette fierté il ya
aussi le coeur qui bat à l'unisson entre
la société civile et militaire
quelle fierté aussi pour nos soldats de
descendre les champs elysées et de deux
d'avoir ces bravo cette reconnaissance
de 2,2 de notre nation il n'y aura pas
ça demain donc c'est sûr que l'abandon
et être un terme à un petit peu fort
mais en tout cas est la tristesse et un
sentiment d'incompréhension
ce sentiment qu'une autre chef des
armées
demain organisé une cérémonie uniquement
pour lui et ses invités alors vous
parliez du manque de moyens on l'a vu
avec avec le ségur de la santé la
revalorisation des salaires pour les
soignants on a entendu depuis des années
le crid alerte de ses personnels
soignants qui manque de moyens
selon vous la situation à ce qu'elle est
comparable dans nos armées aujourd'hui
oui je pense
je pense je me disais service de santé
des armées va mal il ya un manque de
personnel
il faut absolument tenir compte de la
sur-sollicitation qui a été celle du
service de santé des armées depuis la
pandémie kekoli de 19 donc c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est un rapport sénatorial
du 23 juin dernier
ou est ce qui est évident il ya un
manque de personnel il ya un manque de
budget le service de santé des armées va
mal donc peut-être que demain nous
aurons lors de l'interview de notre chef
des armées
une annonce qui en plus donc de mettre à
l'honneur demain le service de santé des
armées dans cette cérémonie restreinte
je le répète ce n'est pas un déclic et
peut-être que notre président va faire
une annonce qui kirabo sens de guédé
notre service de santé des armées qui en
a grandement besoin
pour conclure en quelques mots un
hommage sera également rendu au général
de gaulle par le chef de l'état en
raison du triple anniversaire du héros
de la première guerre mondiale 50e
anniversaire de sa mort
80e anniversaire de l'appel du 18 juin
1940 et 130e anniversaire de sa
naissance
beaucoup de politiques aujourd'hui se
revendique gaulliste
qu'est ce qui a changé selon vous
aujourd'hui dans le rapport entre les
politiques et leurs armées depuis le
général de gaulle c'est une grande
question et qui mériterait débat plus
que quelques minutes monsieur
ceci dit vous savez dans dans le souhait
la communauté militaire dont j'ai fait
partie en tant qu'ex conjointe
on mélange pas la politique est l'art
mais s'il ya une chose sur laquelle je
peux répondre et ça n'engage que moi
parce que les opinions politiques
concerne chacun d'entre nous sommes la
communauté et je me garderai bien d'une
opinion ou non de la commune de la
communauté militaire
je pense que c'est bien c'est bien 7,7
c'était projecteur sur le général de
gaulle
ça n'enlève pas l'amertume et la
tristesse que nous ressentirons 2
nous serons tous devant devant nos
écrans ont physiquement en solidarité on
soutient parce que je le répète nous
sommes fiers nos soldats nous armer de
nos familles de militaires aussi
j'insiste qui ont un rôle important
demain c'était le jour le jour du lien
entre nous militaires nos familles et la
nation il sera tout trop à tout autre
jour à suivre demain monsieur merci
beaucoup redoutent qu'à mercedes crespin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'association soutien et protection des
troupes
également auteur du livre un bon petit
soldat aux éditions flammarion
le royaume uni va consacrer une
enveloppe de 768 millions d'euros
renforcement de ses frontières en vue du
bric site le but se préparer à la fin de
la période de transition du break site
prévue au 1er janvier 2021
cet investissement inclut des dépenses
d'infrastructures et de personnel comme
le recrutement d'environ 500 nouveaux
agents de la police aux frontières et
dans une tribune publiée dans le sunday
telegraph le ministre d'état à michael
gove a assuré qu'il s'agit de faire de
cette frontière à la plus efficace du
monde d'ici à 2025 et pour en parler
nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales en
direct de notre studio de caumartin
claude blanchemaison merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
cette annonce britannique sur les
frontières que signifie tel signifie que
le gouvernement britannique veut montrer
qu'il est paré à toute éventualité le
monde veut montrer à son opinion
publique mais aussi à l'union européenne
et ce quelle que soit l'issue de la
négociation en cours pour un accord de
libre échange avec l'union européenne
que cette négociation aboutisse à un
accord de libre échange ou pas alors de
toute manière le gouvernement
britannique a décidé l'a appelée
beaucoup de fois que la grande bretagne
ou le royaume-uni campagne sortira de
l'union douanière le 31 décembre à
minuit le 31 décembre prochain et on
recrute 500 le douanier et policier des
frontières ce qui est finalement assez
peu c'est assez peu parce que ces
douaniers et ses policiers des
frontières
on va avoir à gérer une situation tout à
fait nouvelle et complexe d'ailleurs
moins complexe très paradoxalement si il
n'y a pas d'accord de libre-échange
parce qu'à ce moment là ils auront à
appliquer un tarif douanier britannique
uniforme à toutes importations venant de
l'extérieur vers le royaume uni
si en revanche il y à un accord de libre
échange eh bien ils devront différencié
en fonction de l'origine des produits
et c'est parfois assez compliqué le
différencier l'origine véritable des
produits puisque à ce moment-là il
rentrerait sans droits de douane dans le
dans le royaume uni s'ils viennent de
l'union européenne et avec des droits de
douane du tarif britannique le nouveau
tarif britannique qui sera mis en
vigueur à ce moment là s'ils viennent de
pays tiers
pour le moment on ne peut pas dire on ne
le sait pas et c'est vrai que le
gouvernement britannique tient à montrer
que l'administration britannique est en
ordre de bataille pour cette échéance
qui est dans quatre ou cinq mois très
proche
ça n'est pas si sûr ça n'est pas si sûr
parce que il faut recruter les
techniciens les douaniers et il faut
également les former alors qu'elle un
silence à l'intérieur du royaume uni et
alain
ailleurs de l'union européenne alors à
l'intérieur du royaume uni il ya
évidemment un problème majeur est celui
des relents puisqu'il se trouve que la
république d'irlande est un état membre
de l'union européenne elle est
d'ailleurs entrée dans l'union
européenne en même temps que le royaume
uni en 1973 et il y à honor de l'irlande
de l'irlande du nord l'ulster qui fait
partie du royaume uni qui est une
composante du royaume uni or à la suite
de l'accord de paix entre premier
ministre britannique tony blair et
premier ministre irlandais de l'époque
plus les unionistes et les nationalistes
du nord de l'irlande
on appelle ça l'accord du vendredi saint
de 1998 et bien suite à cet accord
progressivement on a supprimé toute
trace de frontière entre la république
d'irlande et l'irlande du nord qui fait
partie du royaume uni si vous traversez
cette ligne c'est une ligne fictive il
n'y a aucun panneau les gens circulent
librement les marchandises aussi les
animaux aussi puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
fermes dans ce long de cette ligne qui
fait 500 km alors la grande question est
comment faire pour marquer que le nord
de l'irlande qui fait partie du royaume
uni sort lui aussi de l'union douanière
le 1er janvier prochain alors que la
république d'irlande restent dans
l'union européenne et donc dans l'union
douanière sans rétablir une frontière et
naturellement c'est un enjeu majeur
parce que monsieur boris johnson s'est
bien que s'il rétablit une frontière
physique et bien on ira vers de
nouvelles tensions politiques vers de
nouveaux troubles
et c'est pour ça que dans l'accord
transitoire pour l'année en cours avec
l'union européenne et les prévu un
dispositif assez complexe de poursuivre
suivre les produits qui se dirigeront
vers la grande île irlandaise avec des
procédés numériques d'une assez grande
complexité et reste à voir si cela
marchera du côté de l'union européenne
on a aussi un intérêt à ce que cela
marche parce que personne n'a intérêt à
ce que le conflit qui a duré
trente ans qui a fait 4000 morts soit
ressuscité entre l'irlande du nord et la
république d'irlande
donc c'est évidemment un enjeu majeur et
l'union européenne avaient démontré par
la sa capacité à développer la paix sur
son territoire puisqu'elle avait
largement contribué à cet accord de paix
du vendredi saint
du côté de l'union européenne donc on
tient beaucoup à ça qui est pas
rétablissement d'une frontière physique
alors pour conclure cette dernière
question faire de cette frontière la
plus efficace du monde d'ici à 2025 ce
sont les mots du ministre d'état à
michael gove qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quelles seront les conséquences
mathieu déclaration étrange parce que
j'allais vous dire dans la ligne de ce
que je viens d'expliquer que la
frontière doit être efficace dès le 1er
janvier prochain puisque les
britanniques ont décidé de sortir avec
l'irlande du nord de l'union douanière
de l'union européenne évidemment la
frontière doit être efficace dès le 1er
janvier prochain et pas dans cinq ans et
pas dans cinq ans il y a urgence et en
effet qu'il y est d'ailleurs à un accord
de libre échange ou pas entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne l'union
européenne ne pourra pas s'accommoder
d'un régime laxiste
le premier ministre boris johnson a dit
mais nous mettrons les choses en vigueur
progressivement progressivement non il
ya un changement de nature juridique à
partir du 1er janvier prochain et
l'union européenne appliquera les règles
qui sont les siennes à ses frontières
sont toutefois établir une frontière
physique au milieu de l'irlande alors
effectivement je vous donne un exemple
par exemple supposer que de la viande
australiennes ou néo zélandaise puisse
arriver sans droits de douane au royaume
uni il est évidemment pas possible pour
l'union européenne d'accepter que ceux
ci étant rentré en ulster en irlande du
nord puisse passer puisqu'il ya pas de
frontières dans république d'irlande et
par conséquent sur le marché unique
donc ça sujet d'une assez grande
complexité mais qui soulèvera de grands
problèmes politiques à l'avenir et je
pense que nous aurons à en discuter avec
les britanniques
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse est votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes
vous êtes parent non expert en relations
internationales est resté avec nous sur
rt france dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du gobi de 19 en france et
cette interrogation le port du masque
va-t-il être rendu obligatoire dans les
lieux publics fermés comme le réclament
des médecins et puis la question des
retraites une note secrète du
gouvernement a fuité plusieurs pistes
seraient à l'étude pour mettre en place
la réforme à rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande île père view
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck salle que
ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines l'époque je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
groupe d'avants il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver je pensais
que ça allait me rendre plus tolérante
et ça m'a rendu plus appeler rang alors
parfois elle s'était d'ailleurs je
voulais vous poser justement délirer
autour d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la
pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression pour moi
l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort notre ministre a
interdit immédiatement son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates les activistes et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste on décide
de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trône ici malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types euros qui
vient à manquer les must ne commence à
baisser
au sénégal la chloroquine de maillage
analysé pendant des décennies et des
décennies
ça pourrait faire sourire les sénégalais
quand il n'y a pas de signes qui m'est
rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit ce
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde le président un
brésilien janet jackson arrow ni la
gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de nos activités ou les billetteries
sont à l'arrêt l'impact financier est
énorme
ce sera des matches où conditions 1 avec
port du masque obligatoire distanciation
physique gestion des flux de ce que nous
attendons c'est effectivement la
possibilité de rouvrir sans ces mesures
barrières le plus vite possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021 il faudra
reconstruire le marché cela prendra
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour une heure d'information
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 13
juillet à 2020 l'organisation mondiale
de la santé prévient avec le co lead pas
de retour à la normale prévisible en
france avec un relâchement visible des
gestes barrières et un virus qui circule
toujours à des médecins alertent il faut
durcir la réglementation sur le port des
masques plus de 300 foyers de
contamination ont été identifiés sur le
territoire à les autorités sanitaires
craignent qu'une seconde vague elle si
la réforme des retraites a été mise de
côté ces derniers mois elle n'est pas
enterré pour autant le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire affirme
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'aller au bout
du projet dans son édition du 12 juillet
le parisien a publié une note secrète du
gouvernement
elle contient les scénarios envisagés
pour cette réforme
un dossier brûlant a désormais aux mains
de jean castex
[Musique]
c'est l'un des dossiers les plus
emblématiques des violences présumées
commises par les forces de l'ordre après
18 mois d'enquêté
quatre crs ont été mises en examen après
leur intervention dans un fast food en
décembre 2018 lors de l'acte iii des
gilets jaunes les violences policières
également dénoncé lors d'une marche
blanche à drancy
un an après la mort de philippe ferrière
à la suite d'une arrestation musclée
[Musique]
confronté au co vide le monde se replie
à nouveau plus de 12 millions de cas ont
été officiellement diagnostiqué dans 196
pays et territoires en espagne face à la
recrudescence des cas 1 re confinement
locale en catalogne autour de la ville
de lérida a été ordonnée mais la justice
espagnole a suspendu cette décision des
autorités régionales
[Musique]
un collectif de médecins appellent donc
au port du masque dans tous les espaces
clos mais faut-il le porte est partout
et même en extérieur à la question se
pose notamment après ce concert à nice
et 5000 personnes s'y sont retrouvées
son respect des gestes barrières
conséquence christian estrosi compte
imposer le port du masque aux grands
événements cyrielle bruit une foule
compacte rassemblée malgré les règles
sanitaires actuelles aucun masque
visible sur les images
le rassemblement qui a eu lieu à nice ce
samedi fait polémique
alors que la france craint une deuxième
vague d'infection au co vite 19
rémi recio directeur de cabinet du
préfet des alpes maritimes a préféré
balayer les critiques
nice était belle hier nice donné une
très belle image de sa jeunesse ne l'a
ternie sont pas par des polémiques
stériles
le port du masque n'était pas rendu
expressément obligatoires il n'y avait
pas de phases statiques et nous étions
en extérieur un rassemblement qui
soulève pourtant la question du port du
masque obligatoire face au relâchement
du respect des gestes-barrières une
quinzaine de médecins tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé dans une tribune publiée par le
parisien
ces soignants réclame le port du masque
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
les signataires ont tenu à rappeler les
risques d'un regain de l'épidémie
beaucoup d'entre nous relâcher leurs
efforts depuis quelques jours ou
semaines
nous voulons leur dire et le redire pour
éviter un nouveau confinement masqué
mais en liberté en visite en guyane ce
dimanche jean castex a indiqué que la
question de l' usage développer du port
du masque était à l'étude
d'après le premier ministre cette
réflexion concerne prioritairement les
lieux fermés
un sujet qui préoccupe la classe
politique française nous regrettons que
ces consignes n'ait pas été suffisamment
respectés et demandons à l'état de
revoir le décret qui régit les grands
événements afin d'imposer le port du
masque même à l'extérieur
à nice il sera désormais obligatoire
pour tous nos événements le port du
masque doit être obligatoire dans tous
les espaces publics
je crains que l'épidémie ne reparte le
1er mai dernier marine le pen demandait
le port du masque pour tout le monde
dans l'espace public pour réussir le
déconfinement aujourd'hui ce
gouvernement inconséquent et tu dis le
ligue à sion lui masque encore une fois
marine avait raison avant les autres
alors que depuis plus d'une semaine les
foyers de contamination se multiplient
en france
un renforcement des mesures barrière
pourrait être à l'ordre du jour le
gouvernement a déjà annoncé vouloir
systématiser prochainement les tests pcr
dans les aéroports du pays est en visite
dans la cité azuréenne pour une réunion
sur la sécurité intérieure gérald
darmanin a tenu à rappeler aux respects
des gestes barrières et au port du
masque dès que possible écoutez le à ma
connaissance les rassemblements de 5000
personnes et moins sont autorisés
désormais que les choses ont été faites
en lien avec l'êta qui a autorisé la
manifestation et il s'est trouvé que
dans aucun moment de la soirée
encore une fois pour en avoir échangé
avec monsieur le maire prendra a changé
avec monsieur préfet les choses ont
débordé le cadre organisé par l'état
pour demain et pour les jours à venir
il appartient à chacune et à chacun des
organisateurs de pouvoir réaliser les
choses au mieux j'ai ce matin par
exemple écrit à madame le maire de paris
pour évoquer le fait qu'effectivement
nous devons faire tous collectivement
attention à ce que les manifestations se
tiennent dans de bonnes conditions
sanitaires et que l'état était là pour
concourir et aider effectivement à ce
que la ce se passe au mieux
c'est le cas sur tous les points du
territoire national mais c'est surtout
indépendamment des mères indépendamment
de l'état
à chacune et à chacun d'avoir les bons
gestes il faut être citoyen il faut
porter le masque au maximum des
possibilités
il faut pouvoir tenir ces mesures
barrières éviter effectivement le
maximum de contacts ne pas se serrer la
main ne pas s'embrasser si chacun avait
la possibilité de tenir ces gestes
barrière si chacun faisait quelque chose
pour son pays alors les choses seront
sans doute plus simple
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
catherine hill épidémiologiste catherine
catherine hill merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors la question
des masques toujours elle revient pour
vous est ce que c'est une évidence est
ce qu'il faut le rendre obligatoire dans
les lieux publics clos rendre
obligatoire pourquoi pas mais de toute
façon c'est l'histoire de basque est un
pis-aller
le fond du problème n'est pas là le fond
du problème est dans les tests
il faut tester les gens pour trouver les
porteurs du virus
tant qu'on laisse des porteurs
asymptomatiques se promener et
contaminer les gens autour d'eux on ne
va pas se sortir de cette histoire c'est
ça qu'il faut faire il faut tester avec
le test rt pcr existe à dire chercher si
le virus est au fond du nez c'est ça la
priorité numéro un
alors ce que c'est ainsi qu'au contrôle
l'épidémie alors que l'on apprenait
venant pis-aller alors justement comment
comprenez vous finalement qu'il n'y ait
pas de mesures pour tester massivement
encore aujourd'hui eh bien je ne
comprends pas et on a moyen on peut le
faire
en chine il ya une résurgence de
l'épidémie un peu comme ce qu'on voit en
ce moment en france à pékin
ils ont testé deux millions de personnes
et depuis quelques jours à pékin il n'y
a plus aucun cas il faut tester la
population massivement là où le virus
circule
parce que il ya les porteurs
asymptomatiques qui peuvent être vous ou
moi et leur seule façon d'éviter de
contaminer les autres c'est qu'ils
portent un masque pour ne pas cracher de
virus qu'aux autour d'eux mais pour
résoudre le problème il faut les trouver
et pour les trouver il faut tester tout
le monde alors testé isolés on comprend
bien mais en attendant quand on voit des
rassemblements avec 5000 personnes comme
on l'a vu à nice est ce qu'il faut
porter le masque selon vous il faut
porter masse mais surtout il faut pas
attendre il faut tester il faut tester
en mayenne il faut tester dans la région
parisienne où le virus continue à
circuler et il faut vraiment et ce n'est
pas envoyé des invitations par la sécu
que les gens mettent à la poubelle
il faut vraiment venir en bas des
immeubles et appeler les gens et que les
maires vérifie que tout le monde bien se
faire tester dans la les communes ou
levier
circulent il faut muscler il faut
beaucoup plus cadré aujourd'hui les
opérations de test mais il faut les
faire les tests pas seulement envoyer
des bons gratuits que légèrement mettre
dans la poubelle ont fait pas assez de
tests pas du tout à ces deux tests
alors alors vous vous parliez de la
mayenne justement un foyer qui fait qui
fait naître de l'inquiétude
sommes nous encore dans la maîtrise de
ces foyers aujourd'hui
ben tu en sais rien en plus on n'a pas
de données puis tu rajoutes parce qu on
ne surveille plus de week end et donc je
ne sais absolument pas ce qui se passe
en france depuis les dernières nouvelle
date du 10 donc il ya un problème aussi
de surveillance il faut tester il faut
aller chercher les gens les convaincre
de venir se faire tester c'est pas très
agréable mais c'est pas non plus la fin
du monde d'avoir un truc dans le nez
pour j'allais voir si vous êtes porteur
du virus
mais en attendant le port du masque est
tout de même nécessaire oui bien sûr le
port du masque est nécessaire mais
surtout il faut pas attendre pour tester
il faut arrêter d'attendre
il faut tester alors exactement ce que
directeur de la msa dit à l'entente le f
zero est repassé au-dessus de 1 est ce
que il faut s'en inquiéter
est ce que c'est un indicateur fiable
c'est l'indicateur qui se calcule sur
des bases pas très clair mais en tout
cas ça ne s'est pas le r0 c'est le r du
moment le r0 c'est la propriété du virus
qui est des galas papa 3 et qui reste
constant 0 ça veut dire le point de
départ donc le un effectif le 1er du
moment est repassé au dessus de ac c'est
à dire chaque quart contamine plus qu un
cas c'est à dire que l'épidémie repas
évidemment c'est un problème et dé tous
les insultes c'est basé sur tous les
autres indicateurs le nombre de
consultations sos médecins je ne sais
pas quoi on voit bien on sent bien que
l'épidémie repart les gens font moins
attention il se bouge plus il croise
plus de gens et tout ça augmente le
risque de tomber sur un portage
asymptomatique soit parce qu'il est très
symptomatique qui n'a pas encore de
symptômes la moitié des coûts
domination viennent de porteurs
asymptomatiques risque est grand alors
le retrouver ses porteurs
asymptomatiques
il faut tester alors là encore on va
vous demander votre éclairage on l'a
appris aujourd'hui une étude sur les cas
de kobe de 19 en espagne mener à une
grande échelle indique que seulement 5%
de sa population a développé des
anticorps contre l'infection et que
cette protection peut n'être que
temporaire chez certains types de
patients
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on n'aura
jamais d'immunité collective finalement
un an un orage d'une immunité collective
quand on aura un vaccin
c'est comme ça qu'on a kara une immunité
collective parce que sans ça pour
acquérir une immunité collective avec ar
023 il faudrait que 60% de la commune de
la population 66 % de la population et
était malade et attraper la copie de 19
et ça veut dire beaucoup trop de morts
c'est un insupportable on peut pas
supporter ça mais c'est l'objectif c'est
un mythe mais est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on peut être affecté deux fois par le
coronavirus après la dispute s'est tu ne
sais pas encore
ça ça je crois qu'on ne peut pas
répondre à cette question on peut
espérer que non en tout cas pas dans une
échelle de temps assez assez petit pour
espérer que les gens sont protégées au
moins quelques mois ou jusqu'à ce qu'on
trouve un vaccin par exemple ça ce
serait parfait mais on ne sait pas merci
beaucoup en tout cas catherine hill on
l'aura compris vous appelez à tester
mathy massivement à pour lutter contre
la propagation du coronavirus merci
avoue catherine hill je rappelle que
vous êtes épidémiologistes
faut-il relancer la réforme des
retraites et sous quelle forme la
question se pose alors que le chef de
l'état devrait s'exprimer ce mardi pour
dévoiler le cap des deux dernières
années de son quinquennat déjà des
pistes se dessinent à mener dans son
édition du 12 juillet le parisien a
publié une note secrète du gouvernement
elle contient les scénarios envisagés
pour cette réforme
ah les explications des stèles farges
c'est l'un des dossiers les plus
brûlants la réforme des retraites mise
de côté comme tous les chantiers de
l'exécutif pour cause d'épidémie de kobe
9 elle est à nouveau dans l'actualité
depuis son arrivée à matignon jean
castex s'est déjà penché dessus à
l'assemblée nationale le 8 juillet
dernier le premier ministre a affiché la
volonté du gouvernement de poursuivre
cette réforme
des propos appuyés par bruno le maire
cette semaine le ministre de l'économie
qui la jugent indispensable je pense
qu'il est nécessaire d'aller au bout de
cette réforme des retraites
on voit bien d'abord qu'il y a un
déficit on voit bien que nous vivons
tous plus longtemps on voit bien que
collectivement il faut que nous
travaillons davantage et que c'est une
condition de redressement de la france
loin de l'avoir enterré le gouvernement
a même planché sur cette réforme pendant
le confinement
c'est ce que révèle une note secrète de
la direction de la sécurité sociale daté
du mois de mai et publié le 12 juillet
par nos confrères du parisien
s'il était considéré que le contexte
politique née de la crise sanitaire
rendait impossible la reprise du projet
de réforme systémique telle quelle cette
note et les fiches ont pour objet
d'expertisé des scénarios de réforme de
retraite alternatif au projet actuel
en tout cinq pistes alternatives sont
développés dans ce document la première
consisterait à appliquer intégralement
la fameuse clause du grand père la
réforme ne concernerait donc que les
nouveaux entrants sur le marché du
travail soit ceux nés en 2004 et après
pour les auteurs de la note
cette piste présente je cite la plus
grande acceptabilité sociale mais
pourrait être perçu comme un recul du
gouvernement
une clause du grand-père intégral qui
présenteraient une plus grande
acceptabilité sociale en période de
crise et réseaux nombre de difficultés
liées à la transition en matière de
conditions d'ouverture et de calculs de
droit en particulier le coût des
compensations financières nécessaires à
son acceptation écrivent les auteurs
la deuxième piste présentés dans le
document est celle d'une retraite à deux
étages soit un régime universel
ce socle commun le premier étage
pourrait prendre la forme d'un système
universel limité à un plafond ou d'une
généralisation des règles du régime
général à l'ensemble des régimes de base
indique la note est un régime
complémentaire qui pourrait être divisée
trois privées publiques et non salariés
si pour les auteurs cette piste
répondrai je cite aux critiques sur
l'uniformisation du système de retraite
au détriment du risque selon les
professions et le profil de carrière
il reste toutefois difficile à mettre en
place autre scénario des mesures
d'économies pour remettre notre système
de retraite à l'équilibré
les auteurs de la note suggère selon le
parisien de relever l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ou encore d'instaurer
un âge minimal à partir duquel un
individu pourra partir à la retraite
sans décote à la clé 15 milliards
d'euros d'économies en 2027
deux autres plans d'actions sont aussi
cités dans le document mais jugé peu
probable un abandon de la réforme au
profit de quelques mesures fortes comme
la disparition des régimes spéciaux ou
encore la réduction du nombre de caisses
et de leurs effectifs
l'exécutif devra donc trancher sur la
façon de remettre en marche la réforme
des retraites
un exercice d'équilibrisme puisque le
gouvernement s'est déjà heurté à
certains partenaires sociaux ces
derniers l'ont exhorté à ne pas rouvrir
ce chantier tout de suite pour donner la
priorité à la relance de l'économie
durement touché par la pandémie de kobe
de 19 et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérard filoche ancien inspecteur du
travail gérard filoche bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors si la réforme des retraites a été
suspendue du fait de la crise sanitaire
liée aux comics 19
il n'a jamais été question pour le
gouvernement de l'enterrer complètement
est ce que vous êtes surpris c'est bien
dommage parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus à
faire que de nous casser les pieds
nouveau avec cette réforme mal fagotée
qui n'avait même pas réussi à faire
passer négocier et et comprendre je
rappelle de 70% d'opinions étaient
contre et je rappelle que cette réforme
était argumenté selon des critères qui
aujourd'hui semble bien dépasser sinon
désolé ont décrié et lucas 10 sont ces
critères dépasser pour vous gérard
filoche sait que le contexte économique
qui a changé et qu'il voulait que la
les retraites ne coûte pas plus de 14%
du produit intérieur brut
maintenant il le produit intérieur brut
semblerait avoir baissé de 10 à 12% ce
que les gens imaginent ce que ça veut
dire
on leur retraite avec une baisse du
produit intérieur brut répercuter en
pourcentage 5 et + 14 % de 100% c'est
14% de 88%
c'est un vrai tassement c'est un une
tuerie contre les retraites
ensuite je vois maintenant monsieur le
maire qui livre augmenté les l'âge de
départ en retraite parce qu'on vit plus
longtemps en est-on sûr parce que je
crois comprendre qu'on est menacé par
une nouvelle pandémie où l'espérance de
vie elle même est aujourd'hui menacée et
donc ils sont bien tranquilles de nous
parler pendant 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans 30
ans sans prendre les mesures aujourd'hui
pour confus pour payer nos retraites
il suffirait d'augmenter les cotisations
sociales de 0,1 point 2.3.2 façon à
garder la prestation en ajustant les
cotisations ou ensuite après on nous dit
alors là j'entends des choses
extraordinaires la clause du grand père
justement leur restant se seraient ceux
qui sont nés à partir de 2015 qui vers
2000 65 66 67
on ne sait pas trop bien qui verrait le
mauvais système par points s'abattre sur
eux alors là l'argument avancé était
dire il faut toucher la retraite vite
maintenant pour protéger celle de nos
enfants
il m'attend c'est en tout cas nos
retraites maintenant ce sont de petits
enfants qui vont la payer
alors parce que effectivement gérard
filoche d'après la note
elle précise que cette clause du
grand-père intégral pourrait faire
l'objet je cite d'une plus grande
acceptabilité sociale
ce serait un pari parce que vous n'en
seraient pas concernés mais allons nous
accepter de laisser nos enfants pays à
notre place allons-nous riche et noah
jeu quand je vois ma petite fille judith
est né en 2004 ben c'est toi c'est ta
plus de retraite ma vieille si je ne
bouge pas tout de suite tu n'as plus de
retraite
alors pour l'instant à la 15e
et elle n'est pas tout à fait motivé
mais elle peut comprendre que si
j'accepte la cause du grand-père de ce
foutu gouvernement macron castex et bien
pour elle c'est foutu alors évidemment
c'est un dollar c'est acceptable comme
ils disent cissé il faut attendre 60 ans
pour que le mal vous tombe sur la tête
par contre ils protègent des policiers
de ce mal parce qu' il n'est pas
question chez monsieur qu'accepte qui a
dit que sa première priorité en tant que
chef du gouvernement c'était la police
il n'est pas question de toucher aux à
la retraite des policiers on voit bien
de quoi il s'agit c'est toucher à la
retraite des pouvoirs des soignants des
caissières de tout ce qu'on fait vivre
la france dans les six derniers mois et
de ne pas à toucher la retraite aux
policiers et de reporter sa sour nos
petits enfants dans 60 ans ou 50 ans il
ya c'est aveyron et du square c'est pour
des d'argent parce que gérard filoche ce
qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
d'après la note
la clause du grand-père intégral bon
effectivement il y aura une plus grande
acceptable acceptabilité sociale à mai
selon les auteurs de la note cela
enverrait le signal d'un gouvernement
qui a reculé mais toute façon ce domaine
on reculera qu'il le comprenne au lieu
de s'entêter et d'autre part le mot
acceptabilité humain digne
ça veut dire en fait capituler en
repoussant sa sur nos enfants on peut
pas accepter ça personne peut accepter
ça et donc alors après on nous dit oui
mais on va augmenter l'âge au départ en
retraite
mais en ce moment c'est plutôt l'emploi
qu'il faut augmenter et il place aux
jeunes
place aux jeunes parce que quand on voit
si ces 63 64 c'est les jeunes qui ont
moins de boulot surtout en ce moment
boulot se restreint ce qu'il faut c'est
pas allonger le travail sur la durée de
la vie ni sur la semaine faut le réduire
faut faire 32 eur et 60 ans parce que
comme ça il y aura un partage du travail
et y aura date du boulot pour les jeunes
l'idée même de repousser l'âge de la
retraite alors qu'on nous annonce
pratiquement un million de chômeurs dans
les mois qui viennent peut-être deux
millions de plus et qu'on est déjà à six
millions six cent mille chômeurs nous
aimons c'est celle où dire vous allez
travailler plus sur la semaine vous
allez travailler plus sur la vie et
s'est aggravé le chômage c'est le choix
contraire celui qu'il faut faire il faut
réduire la durée du travail sur la
semaine et sur la vie alors je fasse
enough c'est la méthode du premier
ministre est une méthode de dialogue et
d'écouté ce sont les mots à de bruno
lemaire chez nos confrères de rtl
est ce que finalement avec jean castex
la réforme a plus de chances d'aboutir
dans l'apaisement plutôt qu'avec edouard
philippe selon vous aucune aucune n'y a
pas d'hésitation sur ce plan là il y
aura pas d'acceptabilité plus avec un
sexe qu'avec edouard philippe
et là il y aura pas plus de négociations
tous dénoncé les positions des uns et
des autres pourquoi inventer ce système
par points que personne comprend mais
québec est négatif pour quoi remettre en
course notre retraite alors qu'elle
nageait
on a confiance il disait avant macro n'y
a pas d'argent caché on y vient trouver
430 milliards à donner aux entreprises
et quand c'est les entreprises c'est pas
les salariés 1 sur les actionnaires et
les chefs d'entreprise les salariés ils
se font licencier puisque cet argent est
donné aux chefs d'entreprise et vos
actionnaires sans condition et des
actionnaires on sait bien tout ce qu'ils
font et on met de l'argent dans les îles
caïmans ou bien à hong kong ou bien
ailleurs
et il le met pas dans nos caisses de
retraite un mois je propose linverse
c'est que cet argent il est aux salaires
on augmente les salaires parce que quand
on augmente les salaires on augmente la
part socialisée du salaire le salaire
brut et donc pour fourni de l'argent
pour nos caisses de retraite et ont
fourni de l'argent pour notre santé et
on est capable de faire face aux crises
sanitaires à la protection sociale et à
la pauvreté grâce à ça et ce
gouvernement serait même pas à
comprendre comment il peut en pleine
crise sanitaire inachevé comment il peut
s'engager dans une telle provocation sur
les retraites
une telle brutalité pourquoi pour avoir
raison et disent qu'il faut pas qu'ils
reculent mais macro il est ses options
projet c'est de supprimer les
cotisations sociales
c'est ce qu'il a dit à deux ans y recule
j'espère en tout cas qui reculent ce qui
supprime les cotisations sociales
on est tous n'y aura pas d'argent pour
nos hôpitaux pour nos médecins pour nos
soir en plus de ne pas avoir de retraite
dans 60 ans pour ceux qui seront encore
là pour en discuter
s'il ya quelque chose d'aberrant dans le
fanatisme idéologique à vous à passer en
force sur cette question là par tous les
bouts l'organisme et on va on va trouver
de l'argent quand même alors la crds
elle devait s'arrêter en 2009 ils l'ont
reportée jusqu'en 2024
puis en devient 33 il parle maintenant
de la reporter jusqu'en 2042
donc ils vont faire un impôt crds sur le
salaire qui qui en fait rembourser des
dettes c'est un transfert des dettes de
notre budget social au trou du budget de
l'état c'est aussi aussi incroyable et
je répète ma qu'on disait qu'il n'y a
pas d'argent caché m'enfin ils ont
trouvé des centaines de milliards on va
dire laden mais l île la dette
elle sera jamais remboursé ce qui nous
font croire que la dette soit remboursée
sont deux sont des illusionnistes
gérard filoche changera rien à
l'économie et non retraites défendu avec
choeur par tous ceux qui l'entendent
on la scène et on dit merci beaucoup
gérard filoche d'avoir accepté de
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien inspecteur du travail
et cette édition se poursuit dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
les violences contre des gilets jaunes
dans un burger king en décembre 2018
après des mois d'enquêté gpn a mis en
examen quatre policiers puis nous
parlerons de la vague de reconfirme ans
qui touche le monde après un rebond des
cas de kobe de 19
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction la vie sur terre il
ya d'autres experts qui contestent leur
musique leur donne aux personnes non non
c'est pas vrai il ya des climats tous et
non ce n'est pas rien à part il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs qui
parlent que la presse met en avant parce
que il faut que du débat le ya plus de
débat aujourd'hui
y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers une vraie part
et de catastrophe ou va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas des pessimistes de
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons de vue et les demies
il n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi ceni
et
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde le président un
brésilien janet jackson arrow ni la
gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
prix et en harmonie
oui
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression emploi l'étude
démontre la nocivité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine au nom de la peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société
actis dont certains des employés ont des
qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates et activiste et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste fonds
décide de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
il est 21h30 bonsoir et bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez en direct sur rt
france après 18 mois d'enquêté menée par
l'igpn
quatre policiers ont été mises en examen
pour des violences dans un fast food en
décembre 2018
le quotidien le parisien aujourd'hui en
france a eu accès aux auditions de ces
fonctionnaires ainsi qu'au rapport de
synthèse de la police des polices et
publie quelques extraits des
déclarations des agents mis en cause
cecily à chaumont et airs pissavy
yvernault l'événement remonte à l'acte
iii du mouvement des gilet jaune à paris
à ce jour là à la police reçoit l'ordre
d'évacuer un célèbre fast-food de
l'avenue de wagram où des manifestants
et plusieurs journalistes se sont
réfugiés pour échapper aux gaz
lacrymogènes qui inondent les rues
elle s'en suivent plusieurs scènes d'une
rare violence après la diffusion de ces
images l'en quête pour retrouver les
auteurs des coups est confiée à l'igpn
quatre membres des forces de l'ordre
sont identifiés par la police des
polices pour justifier leurs actes
les agents mis-en-cause évoque un
contexte extrêmement tendu et par le
même de guérilla urbaine
mon unité est intervenue dans un
contexte de chaos inédit pendant plus de
13 heures sans discontinuer à des actes
de violence extrême a les agressions
coordonné par des adversaires
radicaliser dans une situation
normalisée
nos personnels ne serait pas intervenu
de cette manière il n'aurait pas été
dans un état d'épuisement
dehors c'est la guerre vu le contexte on
a agi rapidement on avait pas cinq mille
solutions pour évacuer l'intervention du
burger king représentait seulement trois
ou quatre minutes de notre journée de
guerre civile en 23 ans de carrière je
n'ai jamais eu de problèmes avec la
justice
j'ai l'impression d'être jugé sur
seulement ces trois minutes
je me suis battu toute la journée pour
défendre la république
j'ai seulement fait mon travail du mieux
possible à l'heure actuelle quatre
policiers ont donc été mises en examen
pour faouzi lellouche figurent des
gilles
jaune et johan cavalli l'eau délégué
national crs du syndicat alliance à les
donneurs d'ordres ont aussi leur part de
responsabilité dans cette affaire
emblématique à chaque fois de toute
manière lorsqu'il est intéressant de
police où je m'arrêtais leur d'autres on
a toujours les la jaille harrachis qui
est au dessus qu'ils aient jamais avec
qui j'avais impactés alors que peut-être
ce jour là il ya peut-être eu des
erreurs de commandement
je rappellerai qu'on a laissé 20
compagnies de crs le 1er décembre en
garde statique
là aussi c'est une faute fort pour voir
avec trois compagnies qui manoeuvrait
mais il est trop facile une fois de plus
de se retourner contre les agents qui
font qui reçoit des ordres qu'ils
exécutent et sans que certains soit
exonéré de responsabilités ça c'est pas
tolérable mais le vrai problème c'est
que il ya énormément de plaintes qui ont
été déposées depuis nos événements et on
peut se rendre compte que non là on est
sur l'acte iii imaginez vous tous les
actes qu'il ya eu depuis plus d'un an et
demi avec énormément de plaintes qui
sont retournés sans suite classée sans
suite pour des raisons qu'on n'arrive
pas à définir réellement et surtout pour
une absence d'identification de certains
crs ou policiers
l'enquète se poursuit et les gipn
continue d'interroger plusieurs membres
des forces de l'ordre est si à l'heure
actuelle de membres de la hiérarchie
policière ont été entendues dans cette
affaire aucun n'a encore été mise en
examen pour l'instant et pour en parler
nous sommes avec antoine peillon
journaliste grand reporter au journal la
croix et auteur de coeur deux boxeurs le
vrai combat de christophe dettinger aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent antoine
peillon bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors quatre crs
mise en examen pour violences
volontaires loeb 2 lors de l'acte iii
des gilets jaunes ont souvient de la
vidéo de l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui a fait le tour du web on est
alors à l'acte iii il y a eu beaucoup
plus d'actes ensuite on entendait un des
gilets jaunes faouzi de l'ouche dire il
ya eu beaucoup de plaintes mais peut
finalement ont été suivis quel a été le
rôle finalement de cette vidéo dans le
lancement de cette enquête selon on va
écouter jeu souvenir très précis de
cette vidéo
elle était d'une violence absolument
injustifiable parce que j'entendais les
tentatives de se justifier des
fonctionnaires qui ont été identifiés
les personnes qui ont été tabassés avec
une rare violence ne présentait aucune
menace d'aucune sorte à l'ordre public
elle s'était réfugiée dans ce restaurant
fast-food parce que dehors régner comme
l'a dit un fonctionnaire une ambiance de
guerre civile mais je vais je vais vous
dire très clairement j'en ai fait
beaucoup là des actes de gilet jaune en
tant que journaliste il y avait
effectivement parfois une atmosphère de
guerre civile mais de la responsabilité
principale des forces de l'ordre si que
j'ai vu constamment ce sont des
manifestants qui pour 99% d'entre eux
sont des gens parfaitement normaux
parfaitement pacifique souvent
extrêmement fraternelle d'ailleurs et
qui ont subi pendant un an et demi un
déchaînement de violences policières
la l'événement bon cet événement qui est
rapporté par le parisien est évidemment
intéressant mais il faut lire le
recensement systématique de notre
confrère david dufresne sur halo place
beauvau et sur le site qu'il abrite
maintenant le site de mediapart pour
voir que ce sont des centaines de
violence qui sont absolument
injustifiable dans notre pays et ça
depuis le commencement du au moins
depuis le commencement du mouvement de
gilet jaune mais c'est en réalité tu as
commencé avant mais finalement antoine
peillon est ce que c'est la doctrine du
maintien de l'anc qui doit être revue ou
finalement c'est davantage la vision du
politique des hordes on entendait les
donneurs d'ordre qui doivent là encore
ce finalement se repose sur poser les
bonnes questions
il y a plusieurs facteurs le premier
facteur c'est effectivement une
évolution en france de ce qu'on appelle
la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre et
qui comprend par exemple maintenant
l'autorisation d'usagé d'armes soit
disant non létale mais qui sont en
réalité extrêmement dangereuse
et qui potentiellement sont mortels et
qui en tout cas cause des blessures
irrémédiables
vous pensez bien aux débordements qui
ont été au moins une trentaine les mains
arrachées
voilà les conclusions des visages démoli
et définitivement cette doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre en france est
absolument exceptionnel par rapport à ce
qui se pratique en europe partout en
europe
le défenseur des droits monsieur toubon
a constamment plusieurs fois depuis deux
ans alertés sur le fait que nos
pratiques policières et la doctrine
policière était absolument inacceptable
deuxième chose les hiérarchie policière
couvre complètement leur leurs agents et
elles sont parfois même responsable
certainement par incitations au moins
tacite de cette violence déchaînée des
forces de l'ordre sur les manifestants
tout simplement pour empêcher qu'il y
ait des manifestations
je peux l'affirmer parce que j'en ai été
le témoin sur de nombreuses
manifestations qui ont été brisées dans
l'oeuf
à peine avait commencé alors
troisièmement troisièmement il y a un
pouvoir politique qui le gouvernement
français est depuis en tout cas depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron les choses
ont empiré de façon spectaculaire
elle était déjà sous françois hollande
et sous nicolas sarkozy en aggravation
constante mais avec l'arrivée à l'elysée
de d'emmanuel macron on a senti qu'il y
avait autorisation de faire comme on
voulait et dernier facteur
il est très important il est un facteur
politique
nous avons constaté les policiers avec
lesquels je suis en relation des
officiers de police a été telle gestion
de la scion depuis une quinzaine
d'années au moins une dérive idéologique
dans les effectifs chez les ch et les
policiers chez les policiers en très
grande proportion aujourd'hui il y a une
mentalité politique qui est une
mentalité d'extrême droite assumé des
insignes fascistes sont parfois arboré
sur les neuf sur les uniformes des
petits drapeaux ou d'autres
d'autres manifestations visuel deux
organisations fascistes se retrouvent
dans les commissariats voir ou fenêtres
là encore vous trouverez sur le site du
journal mediapart énormément
d'informations c'est pas tout la police
antoine peillon c'est pas tout la police
ce n'est absolument pas tout la police
mais c'est une proportion suffisamment
importante aujourd'hui pour inquiéter
voir pour décourager les autres leurs
collègues je peux vous dire que y
compris en manifestation j'ai recueilli
des témoignages d'officiers de
gendarmerie ou de police qui était
souvent qui avait de la bouteille qui
étaient des gens qui était officier
depuis de nombreuses années et qui était
complètement dégoûté il n'y a pas
d'autre mot dégoûté par le comportement
qu'il voyait contre lequel il ne pouvait
rien faire de certains fonctionnaires de
police malheureusement très grand nombre
alors il aura en doute a fallu 18 mois
pour retrouver les auteurs présumés des
violences
est-ce que ce délai est il anormalement
longs puisque avec les vidéos et la
connaissance par les autorités des
unités sur place on aurait pu imaginer
que cela aille plus vite non cette
écoute et c'est de l'ordre du ridicule
n'importe quelle enquête judiciaire sur
des sur des faits beaucoup plus
difficile à identifier
étant donné qu'il n'y a parfois pas de
vidéo il n'ya pas d'enregistrement vont
évidemment beaucoup plus vite
il y a comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il ya une couverture on appelle
ça couvrir manifeste une couverture
manifeste des exactions d'un grand
nombre de policiers par leur hiérarchie
l'igpn s'est illustré au point que
d'ailleurs certains demandent sa
dissolution s'est illustré par une
passivité voire par une complicité
évidente vis-à-vis des fonctionnaires
qui se livrent à des deux véritables des
livres ce sont de véritables délit est
pour l'instant l'impunité est quasi
totale tout à l'heure l'entretien que
vous avez diffusé à juste titre
signalait qu'il y a des centaines des
centaines de plaintes qu'ils ne sont
même pas instruite et qui n'aboutiront à
rien
merci
coup antoine peillon d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste grand reporter au journal la
croix et à hauteur de coeur de boxeur le
vrai combat de christophe dettinger aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent et dans
le monde face à la flambée de nouveau
quatre coronavirus plusieurs villes et
pays ont fait le choix de se re confiné
des décisions prises face à la menace
d'une deuxième vague tout de suite le
point en images
[Musique]
e
le
[Musique]
vous
une
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
on
et puis cet âge où on vient de
l'apprendre aux états unis la californie
ferme tous ses restaurants et ses
cinémas une annonce du gouverneur de
californie donc et on revient en europe
où les autorités catalanes iront donc
contre la justice espagnole elle celle
ci avait en effet suspendu leur
confinement décidée par la catalogne le
tribunal de garde de lérida juge que les
mesures prises sont contraires au droit
on le rappelle la région avait ordonné
leur confinement de 200000 habitants
autour de la ville suite à une
recrudescence des quatre coronavirus
étant donné que nous n'acceptons pas la
décision judiciaire le gouvernement de
la généralité prend l'initiative dans
les prochaines heures sous la
supervision d'un conseil exécutif
extraordinaire d'approuver un décret
pour établir un plan de résurgence et
pour pouvoir agir avec toute la force
nécessaire dans tous les coins du pays
en fonction des chiffres de l'évolution
épidémiologique ce plan définira le
système de mesures à appliquer aux
populations et aux régions du pays en
fonction des indicateurs de contagion
c'est à dire un plan réglementant
l'adoption par le gouvernement de
mesures limitant la restriction des
droits et des libertés tels que la
liberté de déplacement et goûter à
présent la réaction de quelques
habitants de catalogne face à cet
imbroglio à lérida il ya des secteurs
qui ne sont pas contrôlés
cela crée une insécurité les gens
commencent à perdre le sommeil parce
qu'ils ont peur la peur nous touche en
ce moment on devra aussi équiper
davantage d'hôpitaux embaucher plus de
professionnels et et c'est tout le monde
et ensuite dire s'il faut confirmer ou
pas il devrait être plus clair et nous
dire nous allons faire ça d'accord nous
faisons ça et nous nous y tenons
mais si lundi une chose l'autre deal
inverse
les gens eux mêmes ne savent pas ce
qu'ils peuvent ou ne peuvent pas faire
maintenant comme il nous confine ça sera
pire parce qu'on va encore tout fermé et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on relèvera la
tête et pour en parler nous sommes avec
roanne rosé dorado journalistes
espagnols à paris juan rosé dorado merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on le disait en espagne
retournement de situation la justice
suspend cette décision des autorités
régionales qu'est ce qu'il faut
comprendre il faut comprendre que le
tribunal catalan effectivement a décidé
de suspendre cette décision du
gouvernement catalan parce que ça touche
aux principes fondamentaux des citoyens
et donc ça serait au gouvernement d
établir le confinement est pas au
gouvernement catalan cela dit ils sont
en train dé négocier pour trouver une
solution juridique à cet imbroglio la
réalité vous l'avez dit c'est vrai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement catalan
souhaite confinée autour de la province
de l'est de la ville de lérida près dé
200 mille personnes pour essayer dé
contenir le foyer qui s'est déclarée
depuis plusieurs jours dans cette région
ddd catalogne mais il faut attendre les
prochains jours plus tôt les prochaines
heures pour savoir que sont les
décisions qui vont être prises sachant
que les gouvernements autonomes sont
armés avec un certain nombre de
blessures qui pourraient prendre pour
éviter la contagion c'est le cas par
exemple du gouvernement de l'arago qui a
décidé aujourd'hui même des limites et
de la mobilité pad est confiné mais de
limiter la mobilité des habitants en
région de l'aragon qui est limitrophe
avec la catalogne pour ça ils sont pris
des mesures telles que la limitation des
horaires des commerces ou encore le
limiter la capacité d'accueil justement
des commerces pour essayer qu'il y ait
moins de monde dans la rue et qu'il y
ait moins de monde dont donc qui bouche
d'un endroit à un autre
en tout état de cause la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui d'espagne quant à peu
près et 120 foyers décontamination les
uns plus importante que les autres vous
parlez de la catalogne
forcément c'est celui qui est le plus
important aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
dire que derrière cette
sanitaire il ya aussi une crise
politique avec cette question de la
catalogne qui leur confient n'est sa
région sans aucun doute parce que à
cette crise sanitaire qui est une
réalité on a additionné une crise
économique on a additionné une crise
sociale et effectivement on additionne
où on aggrave encore la crise politique
qui existe depuis plusieurs années
notamment après le référendum à bord t
est organisée par le gouvernement
catalan ceux-là sur l'indépendance la
réalité et qui est cette décision prise
par le gouvernement catalan est
contraire au droit espagnol mais encore
une fois je pense que le gouvernement
catalan
comme tous les autres gouvernements
régionaux espagnols ont la possibilité
de prendre d'autres mesures pour éviter
le confirme en totale et confinement
total estimé sur qu' aucun gouvernement
aujourd'hui voudraient voir notamment
parce que ça mettrait en danger encore
plus le tissu économique de dans ce cas
précis de la région de la catalogne qui
a été fortement touchés mais aussi parce
que effectivement beaucoup beaucoup
d'aidé des catalans beaucoup beaucoup
d'espagnols de façon générale ne
souhaite pas revivre ce confinement qui
a été vécu pendant quatre mois qui était
très stricte entre le mois de mars le 21
juin qu'on se confirme on s'est terminée
donc il faut trouver une solution
politique et juridique à cet imbroglio
qui existe depuis 24 heures avec la
décision du gouvernement catalan je n'ai
aucun doute qu'ils solution va être
trouvée parce que vous l'avez dit ces
deux cent mille personnes qui sont
touchées et par ac confinement s'il
venait à s'est appliqué en france
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
dit leur confinement est la dernière
solution
c'est aussi le point de vue des
autorités espagnoles
c'est effectivement le point de vue des
autorités espagnoles parce que quand je
vous disais il ya cette crise sanitaire
social et cette crise économique il faut
savoir que le le chômage en espagne va
fortement explosé à la rentrée du mois
de septembre on parle d'un million et
demi de personnes qui vont se retrouver
certainement au chômage on parle d'une
dette qui à la fin de l'année qui va
toucher près dé qui va vers les 10% et
et un pib qui va chuter des prêts des 15
% et à tous
effectivement il ya des solutions des
solutions comme celles qu'on a déjà pris
en espagne là on applique la politique
de gerridae prévenir avant de guérir
et qu'est ce que la plupart des régions
espagnoles par exemple on fait donc
depuis quelques jours pas tout
simplement de l'obligation d'utiliser le
masque par exemple dont la rue à
l'extérieur c'est le cas aujourd'hui des
10 des 17 régions espagnoles
donc effectivement pour éviter le
confinement qui aggraverait la crise
économique y est déjà présente en
espagne
il faut appliquer d'autres mesures et
surtout surtout pas appliquer le nouveau
confirmant comme celui que nous avons
vécu pendant quatre mois une dernière
question quelques mots vous avez le
regard à la fois de ce qui se passe en
france vous êtes à paris mais aussi en
espagne comment est-ce que sert
confinement locaux en espagne est ce que
selon vous ils peuvent arriver en france
d'après ce que vous voyez ce que vous
observez dans les deux pays massaïs
solution intermédiaire entre pas confiné
et confiné complètement scellé
confinement locaux on l'a vu d'ailleurs
au début de la crise ça s'était passé du
côté de l'italie et la mater nos ça se
passe du côté de l'espagne la semaine
dernière c'était en galice où près de 70
mille personnes étaient est confiné et
aujourd'hui on parle de la catalogne au
tour des des douces ont mis là il ya
d'autres foyers
mais c'est la seule façon effectivement
des pouvoirs faire vivre d'un côté une
économie très très touché des pouvoirs
permettre au pays de revenir à une
économie plus ou moins qui marche avec
l'arrivée des touristes est encore une
fois en confinement serait il ne met sur
désastreuse autant dans le plan
politique sur le plan économique sur le
plan social
merci beaucoup juan rosé dorado d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste espagnol et vous
êtes à paris sia et c'est la fin de
cette édition merci d'avoir suivi vous
restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques minutes
on fait un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité a tout de suite
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique